weirdly though josh you have almost a
phobia of doing action i can't do them
have you ever had to do them no okay
well but occasionally you'll be in a
situation where someone will go oh like
can you do an australian accent or
whatever i just
i just can't do it
and like it makes me like um stressed
like my hands go like when i'm stressed
my hand goes like that
and that and
the thought i i can't like comprehend
how you would even start to like
uh like thinking about it
makes
like i can't do it i just i've got this
this is it
and it's not ideal
but you but you you did aspire to be an
actor
well you nearly worked with martin
freeman didn't you i nearly worked
instead of martin franklin
so oh wait a minute i knew so did you
audition for the harbor you auditioned
for the actual hobbit
certain build by baggins
it was a very close run thing i can
imagine yeah yeah who got it i like it
the whole wrong way yeah yeah yeah oh
you know in the hobbit i was yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so i got asked whether
i'd audition for the hobbit
i think on-site alone
like come on like
you'd think right and then i turned up
and i was absolute dog [ __ ]
i thought that like i thought i'm not
gonna get this obviously
but
look at me
i'm going to get some extras work in new
zealand yes
yes that was very quick sorry
i mean what are you talking about but in
venus you are wearing almost a joshua
dick and wig as an apology
that was the worst bit i left they said
can we have your hand
do you remember what bit of you had to
do in the audition well i don't
i don't mean no offense but i'm not into
fantasy at all no you're just like
children's [ __ ] [ __ ]
just encyclopedia
from before you were even at dad
in the night garden
do you know the worst i've tried that's
happened last time i was on it mark
ruffalo accused me of being a pedophile
that's followed me around for five years
yeah and every time i meet somebody go
oh ruffalo was a bit horrible too and
now it's happening again if it happens
once
it might be unfortunate
it happens twice from two unconnected
people
mate
oh god i'm gonna get in a police car and
you're gonna be in the front in the
liverpool accent
and you're gonna be expected to do scout
as well
but no a lot of people in britain went
up for bilbo
nice i'm just saying no it wasn't only
me and you
anyway good
luck i hope it's a bit
me too
[Music]